[Music]
before we get started i just want to
mention that only 21 of you are
subscribed so if you enjoy the content
please consider subscribing to support
the channel hey everyone welcome to
another installment of harry potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing you guessed it fantastic
beast 3 the secrets of dumbledore i'm
going to be pivoting back to regular
harry potter content shortly but right
now this film is a big deal and i'm
loving that there's something new
buzzing in the potter verse naturally
with the release of the film's title
i've been exceedingly curious about what
the film will entail what new things are
we going to be seeing which new
characters where in the wizarding world
are we going to be taken what the
secrets of dumbledore and where did my
curiosity take me why the film's imdb
page of course generally as we more
closely approach the release date of a
particular film the imdb page starts to
populate with more and more information
and with this information we can
speculate derive and sometimes even
extract facts about the film in the
films we've seen so far we've been
introduced to a lot of new environments
places like macusa magical congress of
the united states of america aka the
american ministry paris france and many
more places but we've also been
reintroduced to some familiar territory
like the hogwarts grounds in the film so
far the american hogwarts also known as
ilvermorny has been referenced on
several occasions but we haven't
actually seen the school yet which is
unusual given that we're so closely
following some of the school's graduates
like tina and queenie goldstein so are
we going to see ilvermorny well i sure
think so here's why first of all and
bear with me i've got other reasons to
back this it would be bizarre for the
fantastic beasts series which span the
globe notably the us to simply exclude
such a large element of the film magical
schools are the cornerstone of the
wizarding world to which we've been
introduced and to omit ilvermorny
wouldn't make any sense
years ago in 2016 to be exact jk rowling
wrote an entire origin story for
ilvermorny school where she introduced
us to isolt seya the school's founder
izolt was a famous irish pureblood witch
the only child and daughter of william
and rianak saya and the wife of james
steward together with her husband they
founded ilvermorny school and
established its four houses thunderbird
wampus horned serpent and pukwudgie
ilvermorny can be described as follows
the great north american school of magic
was founded in the 17th century it
stands at the highest peak of mount
greylock where it is concealed from a
non-magic gaze by a variety of powerful
enchantments which sometimes manifest in
a wreath of misty cloud if you want to
see a comprehensive introduction to
ilvermorny and izoltseir check out my
video in the pinned comment okay so
what's my other reason for believing
that ilvermorny will make an appearance
well if we look closely at the casting
for the film on imdb one name sticks out
to me euler lee hicks who is played by
actress jessica williams and why is his
name important why that's because she's
an american witch and a professor at
ilvermorny a professor of charms to be
exact euler makes a brief cameo in
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald when she converses with
nikola flamel via his magic book but
that role wasn't very big and reportedly
euler is going to have a much more
significant role in the upcoming film
with the professor from ilvermorny
appearing more i really don't see how we
could avoid the prestigious american
magical school and that's it for this
video are there any other aspects of
this film that you'd like me to cover
are you enjoying this content or do you
want the regular stuff comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
you